mögen ist eines der schwierigsten
unregelmäßigen verben im deutschen und
wir hören dass auch immer wieder
fortgeschrittene deutsch lernen
diese kommunikation ein bisschen
durcheinander bringen hattet ihr auch
schon mal probleme mit mögen die oben
könnt ihr mal unsere umfrage dazu
beantworten
und wir möchten euch heute die
kommunikation der drei wichtigsten
zeiten von mögen vorstellen
damit ihr das verb demnächst besser
kennt und vielleicht weniger fehler
machen könnt los geht's ich mag ich mag
pizza ich mag ich mag gitarre spielen
ich mag es in berlin zu leben
ich mag meine freunde du magst du merkst
spazieren gehen
du magst pommes du magst du magst
spaziergänge in der natur
sie mag sie mag autos sie mag kochen sie
mag er mag er mag schokolade
er mag pizza er mag autos es mag es mag
sein
es mag sein wir mögen wir mögen tanzen
wir mögen schwimmen gehen wir mögen
passt da wir mögen berlin
ihr mögt ihr mögt shoppen
ihr mögt ihr mögt das schöne wetter ihr
mögt easy german sie mögen sie mögen
essen gehen
sie mögen ihre nachbarn
sie mögen pfannkuchen und sie mögen
[Musik]
partys feiern
ich mochte ich machte frühjahr nudeln
mit tomatensoße
ich mochte keine autos ich mochte früher
diese band du möchtest du möchtest
früher das fotografieren
du möchtest noch nie früher aufstehen
du möchtest diese musik noch nie sie
machte sie machte motorradfahren
sie mochte fahrradfahren er mochte er
mochte nichts in die schule gehen
er machte das noch nie wir mochten wir
machten immer das essen von meiner
mutter
wir mochten gerne ins kino gehen
ihr möchtet ihr machte zum friseur gehen
er mochte die schönen blumen
sie mochten sie mochte nie spaghetti ich
habe gemacht
ich habe ganz besonders frühjahr
gummibärchen gemacht du hast gemacht du
hast das fahrradfahren früher ganz
besonders gemacht sie hat gemacht sie
hat es gemacht im garten zu arbeiten
wir haben gemacht wir haben familien
feiern besonders gemocht
ihr habt gemacht ihr habt es gemacht auf
bäume zu klettern
sie haben gemacht sie haben es gemacht
house partys zu feiern
wenn ihr jetzt eure deutsch zum thema
unregelmäßige verben weiterer tiefen
möchtet dann empfehlen wir euch
unbedingt unsere app sie länger auf sich
lenkt könnt ihr die deutsche grammatik
von a
bis b2 lernen und zwar mit interaktiven
video geschichten in den geschichten
könnt ihr auch aus fahrturnier neue
wörter und die grammatik kennenlernen
probiert das mal aus danke fürs
zuschauen und bis nächste woche
[Musik]